jetzt geht es sogar sehr bekannten
schirmen an den kragen unter anderem der
toiletten papierhersteller hakle ist
pleite während der korona pandemie sie
erinnern sich noch krisengewinner jetzt
dann aber die insolvenz grund die krise
teuer strom und teurer gas und auf der
schuhhersteller görtz ist insolvent seit
fast 150 jahren verkauft die kette
schuhe jetzt ein sanierungsfall und
solche meldungen werden wir jetzt wohl
immer immer öfter hören und auch der
deutsche mittelstand ist bereits am
rande der verzweiflung einer der gründe
diese nebenkostenabrechnung die
gasrechnung von der bäckerei platz
schockiert das ganze land ein
preisanstieg von knapp 720 euro im monat
auf fast
2600 euro ein mögliches todesurteil für
den handwerksbetrieb doch diese
berechnung ist tatsächlich aktuell kein
einzelfall es sind etliche
mittelständige und kleinbetriebe die
gerade in ihrer existenz massiv bedroht
sind
egal wo man hinguckt der mittelstand
leidet beim blick auf die
nebenkostenabrechnung
verzweiflung ich habe eben die neue
heizkosten freizubekommen
erst im oktober gelten und das sind bei
uns ein bisschen zu einer band und das
ist kaum zu stemmen zwei betriebe da
geht also in den sechsstelligen bereich
obendrauf kommen und das ist nach
zweieinhalb jahren
nicht zuletzt thomas metz betreibt das
restaurant eselei in frankfurt dem
52-jährigen graust es auch schon vor der
stromrechnung auch richtig mit einer
erhöhung von mindestens 200 prozent da
wird sehr viel strom gekochten arbeitet
in der küche und da ist ein großer fan
auch was über liegt bei mir in einem
gastronomiebetrieb schon weit über
hunderttausend kw
und da muss ich einfach mit 65.000 euro
aufpreis rechnen bei tim kortüm becker
aus dortmund ist die situation
dramatisch
der strompreis er hat sich mehr als
verdoppelt von
20 cent die kilowattstunde netto auf
über 40 und der gaspreis hat sich fast
vervierfacht von dreieinhalb cent auf
etwas über 13 cent die kilowattstunde
das ist für uns natürlich echt extrem
aber sie haben dadurch mittlerweile
mehrkosten von fast 110.000 euro nur
mehrkosten durch die energie die man
natürlich auch als kleine
handwerksbetrieb gar nicht auffangen
kann der besitzer des führender back
paradies versucht alles damit sein
betrieb überlebt gibt die temperaturen
im kühlbereich schaltet die bösen
schneller aus das reicht natürlich nicht
um das aufzufangen und man kann es auch
nicht an die kunden weitergeben weil wir
sowieso schon probleme mit dem
rohstoffkosten haben dadurch müssten
wahrscheinlich privat halte auch viel
rein stecken jetzt die nächsten jahre in
dem betrieb und so das eigentlich an der
ja der gesamte gewinnen wird natürlich
aufgefressen vielen betrieben droht der
untergang die stimmung ist nicht gut
weil kleine
wir verlieren unsere kunde
und denke ich bin nur hier unser bestes
spiel gekommen kann jetzt einfach diese
seien natürlich ist schwer zu sagen
hekmat talisa de aus berlin weiß nicht
weiter der 27 jährige becker aus
dortmund greift bereits in seine private
tasche wenn wir jetzt kosten
dementsprechend steigen sich natürlich
privat auch viel geld in dem betrieb
einlegen und ja dann muss natürlich ein
bisschen verzichten irgendwo auch mal
auf urlaub eventuell auch ein ja klar im
auto gucken oder das ist auto auch mal
stehen bleibt oder ob man auch überhaupt
alle autos braucht und vielleicht
regional ein bisschen mehr machen gar
nicht so weit fährt spritpreises
natürlich für uns auch enorm da wir mit
ihm auch viel ausliefern ja es ist halt
eine schwierige situation und ich denke
alle müssen da ein bisschen auch privat
ammann wohl schon ein bisschen thomas
metzmacher muss die kosten eins zu eins
an die verbraucher weitergeben david
spiele gegen die das nicht
akzeptieren möchten aber es ist leider
egal ob wäscherei gaststätte oder
bäckerei die insolvenzwelle rollt viele
existenzen stehen auf dem spiel der
mittelstand die säule der deutschen
wirtschaft droht einzustürzen
das sind also die echten probleme der
echten geschäfte der echten betriebe und
der restaurants und jetzt hören wir uns
nochmal den bundeswirtschaftsminister an
was er dazu sagt dass
liegen wir jetzt überall das leben die
darauf angewiesen sind dass die menschen
geld ausgeben blumenläden bioläden
bäckereien gehören dazu dass die
wirkliche probleme haben weil ist eine
kaufzurückhaltung nimmt und dann sind
die nicht insolvent automatisch aber sie
hören vielleicht auch zu verkaufen und
du hast nicht aufhöre zu verkaufen
verdiene ich kein geld mehr da muss ich
die insolvenz anmelden nach zwei monaten
wenn es nicht getan habe habe ich in
st.wendel man würde dann würde dann
insolvent werden wenn man mit der arbeit
immer größeres minus macht ja aber wie
willst du denn kein größeres minus
machen wenn sie leute bezahlen aber dies
wir verkaufen also wie soll man also ich
hab's nicht verstellt ich weiß dass ich
automatisch eine insolvenzwelle geben
geben muss aber es kann sein dass ich
bestimmte geschäfte nicht mehr rentieren
und die dann eingestellt werden
vielleicht werden sie später wieder
aufgenommen das kann ja sein also das
ist dann ja keine klassische insolvenz
aber es kann sein wenn wir keine abhilfe
schaffen dass die
betriebe dakar ein handwerksbetriebe
reinigungsfirmen und so weiter über
dieses jahr dann die wirtschaftliche
betätigung einstellen das ist eine
gefahr und der müssen wir begegnen
eine sehr eigenwillige zusammenfassung
dazu jetzt hier bei uns im studio
bild-chefredakteur johannesburg grüßt
sich guten morgen wie weit ist der
wirtschaftsminister aktuell von der
wirklichkeit entfernt das heil wird
morgen erst man sucht ja es ist in der
tat vollkommen absurd denn das was habe
ich da ja einerseits beschreibt ist eine
klassische insolvenz nämlich als
wirtschaftsunternehmen habe ich laufende
kosten kann aber meine produkte nicht
mehr produzieren folglich nicht mehr
absetzen verkaufen aber also keine
einnahmen aber ausgaben das führt in die
insolvenz die es in deutschland übrigens
auch gesetzlicher sehr streng geregelt
na also es gibt insolvenzverschleppung
heißt er beschreibt etwas
und leugnet aber dass er das beschreibt
sagt das sind eigentlich gar keine
insolvenzen und da erkenne ich ein
wirtschaftsminister der die realität
nicht mehr wahrnehmen möchte vielleicht
ja deshalb nicht weil sie die folge
seine politik ist hab ich hat ja auch
gesagt er sieht keine insolvenzwelle auf
uns zu holen hier in deutschland wie
siehst du das ich sehe eine riesige
insolvenzwelle auf uns zurollen dass es
klipp und klar wir haben im bild immer
wieder jetzt auch unternehmen
beschrieben die es einfach nicht mehr
schaffen zu produzieren oder die ihre
dienstleistungen nicht mehr anbieten
können und die gehen in einem wort
insolvenz wir hatten zum beispiel eine
wäscherei die die stromkosten nicht mehr
bezahlen kann sind in der wäscherei
natürlich besonders hoch weil die
waschmaschinen die ganze zeit laufen das
kann man nicht einfach aus der marge
nehmen also aus dem was eigentlich beim
unternehmen hängen bleibt das ist zu
wenig um diese explodierenden kosten zu
tragen es gehen schon unternehmen
insolvent und da würde ich mir und ich
glaube auch viele bürgerinnen und bürger
außer mir sich einen ganz anderen
wirtschaftsminister wünschen der auf
dieses thema wirklich ein geht statt es
zu verleugnen aktuelle beispiele hakle
gehört der schuhhersteller was ist dein
eindruck schafft es der
wirtschaftsminister habe ich noch ist er
überfordert kann er das noch er ist
vollkommen überfordert und zwar erkenne
ich hier ein wirtschaftsminister der
zwischen seiner ideologie und dem
notfall in dem wir uns eigentlich
befinden nicht den richtigen weg findet
er verharrt wahnsinnig an dem was seine
partei die grünen seit vielen
jahrzehnten gefordert haben und das
allerschlimmste und erstaunlichste auch
gestern in diesem clip bei der ard den
wir gerade eben gesehen haben finde ich
ist eine stelle die zeigt wie er sich da
verändert nämlich er flüchtet sich in
selbstmitleid und larmoyanz es gibt eine
stelle da sagt der wirtschaftsminister
dieses landes er selber habe es ja schon
lange nicht mehr geschafft mal in ruhe
zu frühstücken oder serie zum bäcker zu
gehen da kann ich nur sagen viele viele
millionen bürgerinnen und bürger in
diesem land sind in allergrößter not wir
haben sorge dass sie im winter heizen
können die haben sorge dass im winter
das licht ausgeht und das da der
wirtschaftsminister wenn er nach einer
insolvenzwelle gefragt wird davon
berichtet dass ihnen die zeit für ein
ausführliches oder ein gemütliches
frühstück fehlt das ist völlig daneben
und da sieht man wie er sich verirrt
also kein mitleid und daher sollte wenig
mitleid mit leuten die gewählt sind und
die auch jetzt in dieser notsituation
eigentlich ganz anders handeln müssen
der bundeskanzler hat ja klar gesagt es
kommt jetzt eine zeitenwende ich finde
nicht dass die regierung der der
bundeskanzler vorsitzt vorsteht und
schon gar nicht der wirtschaftsminister
das einlöst und da sieht man ja auch
beim thema atomkraftwerke das habe
gerade auch verliebt hat es sind ja die
grünen kernthemen
kohleausstieg und akw ende und die von
vielen geforderten die geforderte rolle
rückwärts da tun sich die grünen ein
bisschen schwer gefährden sie damit
nicht auch den wohlstand dann von uns
allen mit blick auf den herbst dann auf
den winter doch lisa dass du vollkommen
recht das tun sie und auch beim thema
atomkraft sieht man den habeck den
wirtschaftsminister haarig schwanken
zwischen dem was seine partei einfach
seit vielen vielen jahrzehnten fordert
atomausstieg eine welt ohne
nuklearwaffen
und aber den unbedingten notwendigkeit
jetzt die atomkraftwerke laufen zu
lassen und herausgekommen ist eben ein
ein fauler kompromiss man lässt die
atomkraftwerke irgendwie so halb noch
für drei monate in der hinterhand lässt
sie aber keinen strom produzieren
nur wenn es zu extrem notlagen kommen
würde würde man sie wieder hochfahren
dabei sagt wirklich jeder experte jeder
der sich mit
strombedarf auskennt es ist jetzt ganz
klipp und klar an der zeit in der
energiekrise bei der verzierung der
preise das angebot zu erhöhen und also
möglicherweise nicht nur die drei
atomkraftwerke die im moment noch laufen
am netz zu lassen über den 31 12 hinaus
sondern sogar die drei die letztes jahr
abgeschaltet wurden wieder zu
reaktivieren andere länder daran möchte
ich noch mal ganz kurz erinnern bauen
atomkraftwerke und das ist einfach eine
vollkommen absurde politik die grünen
müssen in der gegenwart regieren sind in
der vergangenheit gefangen so wird das
nichts isoliert er uns damit weiterhin
als wenn du schon sagst dass andere
länder in europa das eigentlich nicht
teilen und dieses ende der atomkraft
nicht nachvollziehen können nimmt er uns
dazu sehr royal natürlich also ich höre
es aus den usa ich höre auch aus vielen
europäischen ländern wo man sagt okay
die deutschen nehmen sich in einer
globalen krise mit dem aggressor
russland mit dem angriffskrieg in der
ukraine mit der aggression durch china
mit einem extrem steigenden elektrischen
energie bedarf im übrigen auch durch die
elektrifizierung zum beispiel der
automobilbranche ja immer mehr autos
waren ja mit strom in diesem zeitraum
nehmen sich die deutschen raus etwas
ganz besonderes etwas ganz eigenes zu
machen sie wissen es besser als alle
anderen länder oder als die allermeisten
anderen länder meinen sie und das wird
uns natürlich im ausland übel genommen
keine frage und die deutschen
atomkraftwerke zählen ja auch zu den
sichersten und saubersten der welt
deutschland ist ja in den letzten jahren
zur hat als eine der führenden
industrienationen auch gegolten haben
wir es uns vielleicht zu gemütlich in
dieser position gemacht haben wir uns zu
lange darauf ausgeruht ja ich gehe oder
ich ich sehe das genauso in deutschland
haben eben die großen industrie
immer den wohlstand gesichert was
deutschland und das auch bereits unter
der regierung von angela merkel
vollkommen verpasst hat ist der
anschluss an eine an ein neues
industriezeitalter an das
industriezeitalter der großen startups
also der firmen die ganz kleinen jetzt
neu gegründet worden sind und die dann
mit digitaler technologie ihre länder
wirklich nach vorne bringen das hat
amerika hervorragend geschafft wo
praktisch sämtliche digitale technologie
die wir hier einsetzen kommt entweder
aus amerika teilweise leider auch aus
der diktatur china wir haben es nicht
geschafft eine eigene industrie
aufzubauen wir schalten sogar noch die
industrien ab die typisch für uns sind
darunter die nuklearindustrie die
atomkraft technik und das führte
wirklich in der düstere zukunft wir
sehen die anzeichen einer
deindustrialisierung in deutschland und
eines endes des wohlstands in diesem
land das muss man klipp und klar sagen
und da hilft es dann eben auch nicht
wenn der bundeswirtschaftsminister ist
sich einfach schön redet die fakten
sprechen für sich droht uns ein
kompletter absturz ja auf jeden fall
bedauerlicherweise ist das so es gibt
natürlich immer auch wieder einmal
hoffnung
ich würde gerne auch mehr hoffnung
verbreiten aber wenn man sich anguckt
wie zum beispiel der anteil der
erfolgreichen firmen deutschlands am
gesamtanteil der erfolgreichen firmen in
der welt kontinuierlich abnimmt da muss
man sagen leider fangen wir an uns von
der weltspitze zu verabschieden und
laufen den wirklich ernsthafte probleme
rein das ist leider der analyse auch
wenn es an der einen oder anderen stelle
hoffnung gibt auch in deutschland gibt
es erste start ups mittlerweile kann die
politik das ruder noch rumreißen was
müsst ihr jetzt passieren dass das eben
nicht so die grünen müssen mit der
realitätsverleugnung aufhören in der
außenpolitik haben sie das schon vor
langer zeit getan da muss ich auch sagen
macht annalena baerbock in aller regel
in sehr sehr starken job auch wenn ich
mit details ihrer politik nicht
übereinstimme aber da haben sie sich
super klar positioniert und meine große
hoffnung ist dass sie solange sie in der
regierung sind es ihnen auch mit der
energiepolitik wirklich gelingt ich habe
aus der partei gehört dass jürgen
trittin das urgestein der grünen zum
thema atom aus tritt soll mit austritt
aus der partei oder mit einem riesigen
aufschrei in der partei gedroht haben
sollten die grünen an der atomkraft
festhalten da kann ich nur sagen klasse
da hätte man gleich zwei fliegen mit
einer klappe geschlagen jürgen trittin
verschwindet endgültig von der
bildfläche und die atomkraft läuft
weiter die energie ist ein bisschen
besser gesichert in deutschland also ich
hoffe dass die grünen zu einem
vernünftigeren pfad zurück finden hoffen
wir alle vielen dank chefredakteur
johannes paul ii danke für das gespräch
danke euch
[Musik]